en el vídeo anterior me quedé con la
pregunta encontrar un intervalo tal que
estemos razonablemente confiados y ya
darle una explicación de esta frase vaga
razonablemente confiados que hay un 95
por ciento de probabilidad de que la
media la verdadera media poblacional que
es igual a p que es lo mismo que la
distribución del muestreo de la media
muestral es decir hay una probabilidad
del 95% de que la verdadera media lo voy
a poner aquí que la verdadera media
muestral de la distribución muestra de
la media muestral está en ese intervalo
voy a arrojar algunas ideas cuál es la
probabilidad de que si yo me tomo una
muestra y me tomo la media de esa
muestra es decir la probabilidad de que
una media muestral tomada al azar esté
entre dos deciles estándar de la media
muestral de nuestra media muestral lo
pongo aquí dos desviaciones estándar de
la media muestral de nuestra
media muestral muy bien entonces
pensemos cuál es la probabilidad de esto
de aquí requerimos ver la distribución
esta es nuestra distribución y esta es
la media muestral ahora voy a cambiar la
media muestra la azul porque así está
arriba entonces cuál es la probabilidad
de que la media muestral una una al azar
tomada al azar esté entre dos
desviaciones estándar ahora este una
muestra al azar es una muestra de esta
distribución tomada de esta distribución
es una muestra de la distribución
muestral de la media muestral
literalmente la pregunta es la siguiente
cuál es la probabilidad de encontrar una
muestra que esté entre dos desviaciones
estándar de nuestra media aquí están las
distribuciones estándar de hecho te
recomiendo memorizar si no lo has hecho
en general pasa que si tienes una
distribución normal la probabilidad de
tomar una muestra entre dos desviaciones
estándar es de 95% 95.4 para ser más
precisos pero podemos decir
aproximadamente de el 95% de hecho
es todo lo que importa ya que tenemos
este lenguaje algo chistoso que dice
razonablemente confiado entre comillas y
de cualquier manera tenemos que estimar
la desviación estándar ya lo cambia 95.4
porque va a ser exactamente eso aunque
las personas equiparan a dos
desviaciones estándar un 95% ahora este
argumento a que es equivalente a bueno
pues este argumento es lo mismo que la
probabilidad de la media de la
distribución muestral que está entre dos
desviaciones estándar es de de equis
barra esto es decir tendrán el mismo
porcentaje 95.4 por ciento estos
argumentos son equivalentes y tengo que
x barra está entre dos desviaciones
estándar de la media entonces la media
está entre dos desviaciones estándar de
x barra es dos maneras de decir lo mismo
ahora que sabemos pues sabemos lo
siguiente sabemos que la media de la
distribución muestral lo mismo que la
media de la distribución proporcional
es lo mismo que el parámetro p la
proporción de la población que es un 1
entonces esto de aquí es lo mismo que la
media poblacional luego este argumento
lo podemos cambiar a p
que da la probabilidad de que pe esté
entre dos desviaciones estándares de la
distribución estándar de x barras es de
95.4 por ciento
ahora nótese no sabemos que el número es
este pero ya hicimos un estimado
recuerda nuestra mejor estimación de
esto es la verdadera desviación estándar
de la población dividida entre 10
podemos estimar la verdadera desviación
estándar de la población con nuestra
muestra de desviación estándar la cual
fue de puntos 5.5 dividido entre 10 la
mejor estimación de desviación estándar
de la distribución muestral es de 0.05
ahora puedo decir cambiar de color
decir que la probabilidad de que el
parámetro p la proporción de la
población con 1 sspe
entre 2 x y recuerda nuestra mejor
estimación de esto aquí es de 0.05 por
ciento entonces de una media muestra que
tomemos al azar es igual al 90 y 5.4 por
ciento hasta aquí todo en orden esto es
igual a que la probabilidad entonces la
probabilidad de que p esté entre 2 por
0.5 0.05 es igual a 0.10 de nuestra
media es igual a 95% y debo tener
cuidado aquí debo tener cuidado porque
no puedo decir el igual porque si
supiéramos esto si conociéramos el
parámetro de la distribución nuestra de
la media muestral podríamos decir que es
de 90 y 5.4 por ciento no lo sabemos
sólo estamos intentando encontrar la
mejor estimación para esto entonces
tacho y digo que esto es aproximadamente
95 por ciento estamos razonablemente
confiados de que es un 95%
porque si estamos usando este estimador
que salió de nuestra muestra y nuestra
muestra está algo torcida entonces nos
va a salir un número muy extraño
aproximadamente 95% por eso debemos
tener más cuidado ser más exactos con lo
que estamos haciendo o podríamos decir
que la probabilidad de que p está entre
el 0.10 de nuestra media muestral que
obtuvimos cuál fue la media muestral que
obtuvimos pues fue de 0.43 entonces si
estamos entre el 0.1 de 0.43 significa
que estamos entre el 0.43 + - punto 1 es
también aproximadamente estamos
razonablemente confiados de que es un
95% ahora quiero ser bastante clara todo
lo que he hecho desde el color café
amarillo hasta el morado simplemente re
argumentado lo que es en el paréntesis y
todo llegó a ser bastante cómodo desde
que partir de la desviación estándar
exacta de la distribución muestral hasta
llegar a un estimador para el mismo
y por eso puse el símbolo de congruencia
indicando que estamos razonablemente
confiados de hecho hasta me deshice de
alguna precisión en 95.4 por ciento pero
que creen acabamos de encontrar el
intervalo un intervalo tal que p éste
entre en 0.43 + menos punto uno estamos
razonablemente confiados un 95% de que
pp está ahí tenemos entonces un
intervalo con el 95% de confianza y
podríamos decir que del 0.43 menos punto
uno es punto 33 que he visto en
porcentaje sería 33%
y si le sumamos el punto 1 0.43 + 1
tendríamos el 53% entonces estamos un
95% confiados nótese que no estoy
diciendo que un 95% es precisamente la
probabilidad de la proporción no pero
que estamos un 95% confiados que la
verdadera proporción está entre 33% al
53% es decir que p está entre ese rango
otra manera de decirlo y lo verás en
muchos estudios las personas dicen
hicimos un estudio y obtuvimos que el 43
por ciento votaran por uno y en este
caso uno es el candidato b entonces 43
por ciento votarán por el candidato vez
de aquí se sigue que el resto votarán
por entonces el 57% 57% votarán por el
candidato a y luego verás que pondrán un
margen de error y este esto lo ves en
cualquier estudio que pasan por tv
pondrán un margen de error y este margen
de error no es más que otra manera de
describir este intervalo de confianza
este intervalo de confianza y dirán que
es un margen de error en este caso de un
10% que significa que hay un intervalo
de 1
5% de confianza si hacemos más menos un
10% de este valor el 43 por ciento
ahora quiero poner énfasis no puedes
decir con certeza que hay un 95 por
ciento de probabilidad de que el
verdadero resultado esté entre el 10 por
ciento de esto porque tuvimos que hacer
una estimación de la desviación estándar
de la media muestral esta es la mejor
medida que vas a obtener con la
información que tienes si haces un
estudio de 100 personas y si ves bien
10% es bastante grande si observas
dirías aproximadamente hay un 95 por
ciento de probabilidad de que el
verdadero valor de este número está
entre el 33 y el 53 por ciento entonces
el candidato aún tiene oportunidad si lo
quieres más preciso tomas más muestras
puedes imaginar tomando en lugar de en
igual a 100 haces en igual a 1000 luego
el número ese lo divides entre la raíz
cuadrada de 1000 luego el margen
año de la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestra bajará entonces la
distancia entre las dos desviaciones
estándar será un número más pequeño y
por lo tanto tendrá su margen de error
más pequeño y es lo que quiere es hacer
el margen de error más pequeño tanto
como para saber quién gana las
elecciones y listo
terminamos hasta pronto